non so se vi ricordate the killing the
killing quel gioco dove tipo hunger
games
solo che io faccio un po schifo a
giocare lì io ho scelto una persona
affidata con la quale buona visione
ragazzi venga vengano vengo io che
ritroviamo a metà perso e quindi eccoti
la ok ma io kraft ato delle cose qua ho
sbagliato
va bene ma venga quindi il lusso ma un
po di armi soprattutto lei allora
capisci solo tu vendi dove vai
ci sono le porte di questo vendilo rouge
un ok bravo che è il tubo di armi per
fortuna ho trovato un po di armo signor
gatto guardie bello mettetela bravissimo
e l'ho messo gli piace non è il mio
genere c'è un cazzo per l'insegnante
loretta via c'è gente sul posto a destra
al centro centro se loro andiamo dentro
questa casa superamento la roba sono
morti tutto il suicidio ci hanno visto
contro eni aiuto faceva un cazzo e lo
piccolo
ma c'è gente che prende fuori venga poi
li faccio io gli ho dato un pugno a
questo ma nicola orto ravalli li culata
che male che fanno graziare pc gamer
permesso lo so tutto signor gatto le
linee di picchi picchi forte che se no a
un cammino non sai che di male
ovvio che c'è backstage fa male agli
alberi numerico da aia che mai
i tiri su portiamo l'italia in alto e ma
questa è gente che giocava alla persona
ma in un'ora di live non faremo una kill
io non la vedo nera non so cosa dove
esiste e va bene quanto è distante e
niente le in un'altra mappa 300 metri
dai che se sarai mai credo di sentire i
passi potrei sbagliarmi interna che
forse sono già morto finita qui c'è
tutto aperto ma no è che ogni tanto ci
sono bugiardi kakà io vedo un tizio
signor gatto c'è una persona che porca
miseria la pila picchio no scappi scappi
lasci perdere scasso 6 al pescato lascio
perdere perché se no non me lo prende
signor gallo fa in va bene non facciamo
questa come positiva ma è possibile che
non mi prende lo zaino con la e con la
ieri mi rende la lancia via quella fare
meglio ma lo rifacciamo non pensavo
facesse danno ci sia la gente sa c'è
gente ai e per parte al peggio bene e va
beh hanno vinto loro aiuto mito signor
gato che qui questi settimanale
dissimili mammamia preparano i colpi
questi sono proprio ragazzo sa che
continueremo così tutto il giorno io e
lei perdere e gente che ha giocato solo
dei cali perduto negli ultimi due anni
come spera di poter più vuole tornare su
auto guardi piuttosto non lo so io mi
divertivo però ci si troppo forti non so
guardi male lo speaker è di cose le
volte noi possiamo continuare
se perdiamo di tensione la gente che sa
solo questo tema ci siano arrivo ed
entriamo ciò c'è una persona
vabbè prendete il martello che là dove
l'ho visto mi raccomando da col tasto
destro ci si para
si si lo so però prendo comunque mazzate
vede una iai ceac se è bravo escluso 50
però che lo dico come questo 50 le unità
in cui era verde eccolo e picchi ma non
male perché male giocattoli o lanciato
il patto che lo piccolo picchi niente e
rocky balboa abbiamo ucciso aver ucciso
si fermi si fermi e morto la nostra
unica kill godetevela spettatore perché
la persona vi aspetta tu non hai lo zen
esco mettitelo che jane è quello là ciao
ciao
adesso me l'ha preso o le fatiche ogni
volta è bello non sono necessari degli
zaini vorrei che non ascolta c'è il
mentre che leggimi numero ce lo schermo
per tenga facciale hyoun ko rimasto di
lanciare le cose sono capaci equa e
bellissima la fisica che hanno gli
oggetti
il bilancio è bellissimo
dovrei dosimo mamma mia che porte avrà
fra giù le mani ho pensato e non voglio
vedere marco gatto everdeen niente resta
le cose
randal prenda tutto le frecce le altre
24 tra l'altro non male e abbiamo tutti
i manuali e bravo a sparare da lontano o
ma mi fido
va bene andiamo ma ti mancano vediamo
tutti i curatori del morto le sorti uno
che abbiamo ucciso noi non scaglia ma
lei è pazzo ma lei è scemo ma quest'uomo
ha dei problemi ma io non gioco più con
le ma lei l'ospite in live addirittura
cioè non ho parole
pensi se eravamo da soli che avuto un
affare del raccolto
l'ho preso non ti curar va messo sei ore
a farlo ci mancherebbe altro non farlo
con la granata in mano la macchina mi ha
appena detto sei un maschio e una
femmina se fossi dottore ti fa ridere
questa domanda professor hoc
cosa vuoi fare giocartela safe stare
distante oppure avvicinarsi e col volo
guardi e credo che in ambedue i casi ce
la prenderemo bellamente del deretano
quindi che giovanissimo ho capito sono
contro due arcieri di merda ayachi e
male
l'hack è mai niente sono due arcieri e
che liscio e da lì ma sembra penso
vedendo frecce che ma come fatti
impianto affitta freccia nel cespuglio
mi avvicino ed ora mo lo chiamo e
andiamo d amico via signor gas via via
via è male che male forse però troppo
cui tecnocasa gen
era dato fuoco qualcosa ai a faccia
qualcosa distragga urli urli
ecco sopra di noi freccia lo tirano giù
bravissimo signor gatto con chi pensa di
parlare
e vabbè però attenzione per scoppiare
gli sia distante per puro una
mitraglietta
se non mi vince questa partita guardi ai
ceci gente soprattutto li ho visti o
ecco lì dove sono
che paura dove è scemo lei non ho
sparandole ai quali d'altra parte
spettacolo colpito al centro centro
centro centro vedo dove soffre sopra
centro centro sopra aspetta aspetta che
mi ha guidato uno mi ha visto e sta
facendo il giro io mi sono pagato vengo
da lei mi ha fatto malissimo colpito ma
non levano niente le frecce signor
chiede anche il mentre niente
effettivamente federato sparisco non ci
sono più chiuso uno ucciso mega qua
venga qua signor gatto dal mezzo
indietro tanto tempo ha detto picchi
picchi riconsiderarlo picchi picchi si
resista che lo tesero utensili lo
tesserato pink i picchi da dietro
dell'euro tesero ancora e non posso è
carico e scarico picchi per nokia noi
due donna si enuncia ora era era rocky
balboa wheaton però sono soddisfatto
perché abbiamo fatto molto di più di
quanto mi sarei mai aspettato la si può
giocare in b di guerra
mi squadrano pro si può fare il server
fino a 16 il problema è trovare altri
giocatori come al solito problema è
trovare lei quando inizia la partita ma
non vedo neanche segnalino eccolo io non
so se venire da lei o farmi cazzi miei
ma sa che le dico faccio i cazzi miei
l'hotel un sempre fatto nella mia vita
l'urto e campani non l'ha con la madonna
se arriviamo alla fine cede io non la
conosco
anzi due li amo esatto esattamente
quello che dicevo quando sentirlo delle
macchinette perché li sto usando
qualcuno lo fanno sendo fanno sempre per
far vedere che dovevamo segnare ho già
cacato permesso
vediamo suo terzo lorenzo signor gattoni
caghi si sono appostati ho visto che noi
seicenteschi sparano sparano significato
visto ci sarà io vado via
casey in cui il suo estro marcia è un
cecchino dentro mais in cui lei lei la
foto che scade aglio che muove anche
tensione felice della gente agli animali
ma do prado che arma il cecchino che non
è un giochino di per terra davanti a lei
bravo è esploso un tizio si erano né
cremano sulla destra quando sulla destra
e quali no e basta vale questo l'anno
prendeva aver disarmato ma non funziona
ma questo gioco è tutto scene vabbè ho
provato a sparare niente i ragazzi sono
costruito vi sia piaciuto signor gatto è
stato bravissimo molto bravo come me
il che la dice tutta questo video vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cosa se riuscirò a me
piace ancora il socialismo dalla
descrizione sapersi sky e non ci vediamo
da ragazzi
[Musica]